[Musique]
quinze mille recrutement c'est le nombre
d'emplois à pourvoir dans le secteur de
l'aéronautique en france en 2019
bienvenue au salon du bourget pour un
numéro spécial de mode d'emploi
consacrez vous l'avez compris aux
métiers de l'industrie aéronautique sur
saint quentin en yvelines c'est parti
pour le sommaire c'est un grand groupe
de l'aéronautique et de la défense
installé à saint quentin en yvelines
l'entreprise thalès plusieurs sites
implantés à elancourt recrue de 450
personnes en cdi en 2019
nous avons rencontré le responsable du
recrutement de thales en france c'est
l'avion de combat de l'armée française
le rafale conçus par le groupe dassault
aviation certaines pièces sont
fabriquées par des pme c'est le cas de
son antenne produite par hbo wayne
jacquelot péclier une entreprise
installée à trappes
enfin découverte de l'activité de
permaswage sept entreprises américaines
implantées aux clayes-sous-bois fabrique
les tuyaux essentiels au fonctionnement
des avions
nous avons visité l'usiné de cette
société
[Musique]
l'aéronautique un secteur historique et
important pour saint quentin en yvelines
le territoire accueille 60 entreprises
pour quatorze mille emplois des grands
groupes présents sur le territoire comme
safran thales ou encore airbus et des
pme qui nouent des partenariats avec ces
grands groupes
les détails dans ce reportage saint
quentin à l'intérieur de l'île de france
et le donc le territoire où il ya le
plus d'emplois de cette filière
aéronautique
je rappelle que la france globalement et
oui on vient d'être confirmé que ce
salon je crois notamment airbus et
numéro un mondial devant boeing
cette filière aéronautique est les
premiers excédents de la balance
commerciale française
[Musique]
bien sûr il ya les gros safran des
sceaux airbus thales mais on a aussi les
petites pme et voilà nous on se on se
bat bien sûr pour que ces différents
vivier vivent ensemble se développent
ensemble bien sûr aider les petits à
grossir dd beaucoup plus aux entreprises
en termes de recrutement parce qu'il ya
un problème de recrutement
donc là dessus on augmente la présence
des grandes écoles on augmente le nombre
de deux jeunes ingénieurs
il faut savoir qu'ici saint quentin vous
êtes dans paris saclay vous avez les
plus belles écoles d'ingénieurs je vous
le rappelle à tous les niveaux ça va de
polytechnique a enfin tout aux grandes
écoles aussi bien sur la chaussée
centrale supélec que normale sup
sciences où les écolos six nageurs comme
l'estaca très spécialisés sur les rangs
de fric ils sont déjà trois mille six
cents salariés de thalès répartis sur
les différents sites d'elancourt des
ingénieurs des techniciens spécialisés
sur la question de l'aéronautique la
défense et la sécurité
pour 2019 l'objectif est de recruter 450
nouveaux collaborateurs et pour en
parler nous sommes avec vincent mattei
bonjour bonjour vous êtes responsable
recrutement pour thales en france ça
fait alors est-ce que vous pouvez nous
expliquer les missions qui seront
confiées à ces 450 nouveaux
collaborateurs tout à fait alors sur
elle encore nous avons prévu en effet
450 recrutements cette année dans
différents types de métiers la r&d
logiciel matériel d'ingénierie système
mais pas que beaucoup de postes à
pourvoir aussi en industrie support
client et dans la gestion des projets
des programmes dans des environnements
très variés
guerre électronique optronique
l'électronique domicile mais aussi dans
les systèmes d'information sécurisés
concrètement c'est quoi ces de la
programmation qui vont être amenés à
faire c'est du développement pas que
c'est là du développement c'est de la
programmation mais aussi ses de
l'industrialisation des produits des
systèmes que l'on propose à nos clients
pourquoi il est nécessaire en 2019 de
recruter 450 nouveaux collaborateurs
c'est énorme non c'est beaucoup en
france thales prévoit de recruter 2500
personnes
il y a plusieurs raisons une activité
business qui se porte bien mais aussi
c'est lié aussi à des départs en
retraite
donc les deux cumulés font qu'on va
recruter 450 personnes environ sur
elancourt cette année sur l'évolution de
l'activité à elancourt est-ce que vous
avez des chiffres à nous donner c'est
une évolution plutôt croissante de plus
de trois ans en termes de volumes de
recrutement
et sur l'ensemble des activités que vous
avez présenté tout à fait alors pour
rentrer un peu plus en profondeur dans
le sujet que vous recherchez quel type
de profil alors par rapport au métier on
va rechercher en termes de profil à la
fois des ingénieurs issus d'écoles
d'ingénieurs d'université scientifiques
notamment pour les métiers de la r&d
pour les métiers de l'industrie mais
aussi de la gestion de projet de
programme mais aussi beaucoup beaucoup
de profils je tiens à signaler de
profils de techniciens donc bac bac + 2
dut qui vont intervenir et
majoritairement des technicien en
électronique qui font soit de la
production soit de la réparation donc à
la fois des profils plutôt master 2 mais
également de type bts dut en
électronique faut avoir l'expérience
pour postuler à ce type de poste
alors on a deux typologies de profil
beaucoup de jeunes diplômés
le groupe thales recrute depuis pas mal
d'années 50% de jeunes de moins de 30
ans donc on peut être débutant après un
stage une alternance mais également bien
sûr dans les différents environnements
des profils expérimentés
vincent mathy merci beaucoup et si vous
êtes intéressés par ces offres d'emploi
n'hésitez pas à postuler sur le site qui
s'affiche en bas de l'écran
[Musique]
nous sommes sur le stand du gifas le
groupement des industries françaises
aéronautiques c'est une fédération
professionnelle regroupant 400 sociétés
des grands groupes et des pme
elle permet de créer des partenariats
dans la filière entre ces sociétés c'est
le cas notamment du groupe bowane
présent à trappes avec sa filiale
jacquot pleky et nous sommes avec jus
bellino da silva le président de ce
groupe bonjour alors déjà est-ce que
vous pouvez nous présenter le groupe
boën boën est un ensemble de sociétés
qui s'est créé depuis 2003 mais qui en
fait existe depuis 1921
vous allez nous allons fêter notre
centenaire dans d'ici deux ans donc et
j'espère que le prochain
bourget on fêtera nous nous sentons donc
en fait c'est un groupe qui a pour
particularité d'intégrer des
connaissances très disons spécifiques
dans le domaine des radiofréquences et
des technologies perd donc ça va de
l'antenne avec toute la partie réception
derrière l'antenne et des traitements
logiciel au numérique
après ces réceptions un de vos produits
par ces l'antenne du rafale ici oui
c'est ce que vous allez pouvoir entendre
là et tout à l'heure à 13h30 il y avait
d'autres les démonstrations
effectivement ça équipe toute la partie
un peu spécifique de la guerre
électronique du rafale c'est un élément
stratégique leurs fans alors à quoi sert
cette antenne alors c'est une antenne
que vous développez notamment avec un
autre grand groupe thales thales
effectivement nous sommes partenaires de
thales dans la fabrication de ces
systèmes
ce sont des systèmes de détection ce
qu'on appelle de la guerre électronique
et donc ils permettent de détecter des
cibles
pour protéger en fait dans ma phares et
de systèmes da alors je suppose qu'avec
les nombreuses commandes de pays
étranger du rafale
votre activité progresse vous avez la
croissance nous sommes en pleine
croissance
actuellement la en l'espace de cinq ans
ben haddou plaît et nous avons la même
perspective pour les 5 10 prochaines
années
alors on va voir le reportage juste
après sur l' usine à trappes mais un mot
vous pouvez vous nous présenter cette
usine l'activité qu'est ce qui s'y passe
dans cette usine à trappes à cette usine
est extraordinaire dans la connaissance
physique
en fait c'est unique et une un endroit
où le manuel le savoir-faire le process
est extrêmement important depuis 40 50
ans ce sont des gens qui savent faire
des antennes en utilisant des matières
des matériaux des peintures qui sont
pour le coup qualifié avec des process
vraiment particulier et c'est un savoir
rats et je pense que si on continue à
travailler pour thales pour la dge pour
une bd à dans ces domaines c'est à cause
de ça c'est à cause de la connaissance
des hommes en fait un mot sur la
collaboration entre pme et grands
groupes comment ça fonctionne
aujourd'hui alors
pour nous bohème j'avoue que ça se passe
plutôt pas trop mal parce que on a un
niveau technologique qui fait qu'après a
priori on peut se défendre entre
guillemets bon voila mais toujours on a
toujours ce ce cette difficulté des fois
entre clients fournisseurs il ya des
problèmes de compétitivité de prix donc
vous imaginez ce qui peut se passer au
niveau d'une négociation donc ça c'est
le côté un peu négatif même et par
ailleurs il faut quand même rendre à
cela une réalité industrielle qui est
par exemple qu'un groupe comme thales
travaille depuis toujours quand je dis
toujours c'est 30 ans au moins
avec avec le site de trappes et avec
tous bauwen boën au travail avec c'est
l'ensemble de ces différents groupes
militaires aux civils depuis très
longtemps
voilà en plus le positif c'est que
thales vous êtes juste à côté un thales
et à elancourt à la com ça va dire le
seul dont les branches sont simples sont
simples rapides et c'est aussi ça qui
fera notre futur parce qu'on croit
beaucoup que les systèmes intégrés de
demain ne se feront qu'avec de la
proximité
il est impensable contenu des
technologies qu'on est en train
d'embarquer en ce moment on puisse le
faire à des dizaines de kilomètres ça
c'est une vue d'esprit ça marche pas si
vous voulez mettre des compétences très
performante
il faut que les gens travaillent
ensemble il faut qu'il coopère un
dernier mot juive et lino da silva les
défis de demain pour le groupe borel que
moi je ne souhaite qu'une chose c'est
que on embarque nos produits de plus en
plus et que ses solutions et un retour
d'expériences réelles m'embarquais c'est
mon seul souci c'est de faire de la
belle industrie pour qu'elles soient
embarqués dans nos systèmes
je vais lino da silva merci beaucoup de
nous avoir reçus sur le stand du gifas
et puis donc je le rappelle vous êtes
président du groupe boën et on va
prendre la direction de deux trappes
injustement pour découvrir concrètement
l'activité de vos collaborateurs nous
nous sommes rendus dans les ateliers de
votre filiale jacquelot péclier un site
classé secret défense se regarder ce
sont des orfèvres de l'aéronautique ils
sont intégrateurs électronique câbleur
ou encore technicien polyvalent
au total 25 personnes sont employées
dans ses ateliers de la société boën
jacques laulhé cli implantée à trappes
on travaille soit sur system système
antennes est en fait effectivement sur
des sur des produits qui va se monter
sur l'aéronef en fait ça ces appareils
qui permettent de communiquer soit avec
une un émetteur qui est situé soit en
vols soit au sol télécommunications et
antennes pour l'aéronautique la
spécialité de cette société en pleine
croissance de son activité elle
recherche des nouveaux collaborateurs
notamment dans la conception de câbles
et l'intégration électronique
il ya de la coupe de câbles et du
raccordement
donc il faut souder des connecteurs sur
les prises bien spécifiques
alors ici nous avons des cartes à
intégrer donc nous avons des cartes
vierges avec mise de composants il faut
connaître
savoir soudé et une bonne expérience
aussi dans les composants savoir lire et
des chiffres est aussi les plans après
la production vient une phase de
contrôle notamment pour les antennes
c'est voir cette fonction c'est voir ça
répond qu'à rester ici que demandée par
les clients c'est voir si si l'entamé
correctement assemblé et intégré que
tout se passe bien les post
d'intégrateur électronique et de câbleur
sont à pourvoir dès à présent vous le
découvrez derrière moi le tout nouvel
appareil lancé par airbus l'a321neo et
il est notamment équipé par les produits
de permaswage cette multinationale
américaine est spécialisée dans la
conception de systèmes hydrauliques pour
les avions sa filiale est installé aux
clayes-sous-bois depuis 1974
nous sommes allés découvrir cette usine
les images sont signés aurélie rose
ces morceaux de tuyaux sont présents
dans l'a320 le rafale et des
hélicoptères mais on ne les voit pas
assemblés ils composent un système de
raccordement c'est la tuyauterie
aéronautique
ces raccords sont des pièces qui sont
design et est fabriqué ici aux
clayes-sous-bois elles viennent donc
raccorder ensemble des tubes sur les
aéronefs ses tubes permettant de
véhiculer différents fluides
ces tuyaux transportent des fluides
hydrauliques pour les commandes de vol
le carburant ou encore de l'air
permaswage multinationale américaine
possède une filiale en france un site
implanté aux clayes-sous-bois avec un
chiffre d'affaires de 100 millions de
dollars
la croissance est plutôt bonne elle est
effectivement lié à deux facteurs la
croissance mécanique de l'industrie
aéronautique mais également une
croissance liée à nos développements
propres c'est-à-dire des nouveaux
produits quand que l'on a pu proposer à
nos à nos clients et qui ont été
intégrés sur des nouveaux programmes
comme l'a350 par exemple airbus
l'italien leonardo ou encore le suédois
saab des constructeurs aéronautiques
clients de permaswage aux
clayes-sous-bois 150 personnes sont
employées autour des tours en commande
numérique pour fabriquer les pièces
régler les machines par rapport à un
programme
réglez les outils et faire l'usinage
surveiller les côtes et que toute la
série ou que la pièce unitaire soient
bonnes à l'ap hm j'adore ce que je fais
depuis 15 ans bah je suis coincé je
m'épanouis dans ce domaine actuellement
père maciel recherche de nouveaux
collaborateurs avec des formations en
mécanique pour un salaire annuel entre
25 et 35 milles euros par an vous pouvez
postuler à l'adresse mail affiché en bas
de l'écran
c'est à côté d'un hélicoptère utilisé
par l'otan est conçue par plusieurs
entreprises européennes à airbus
leonardo et fokker que je vous annonce
la fin de cette émission merci de nous
avoir suivi on se retrouve le mois
prochain pour un nouveau numéro de mode
d'emploi
[Musique]